Unlike earth,
which is orbiting the sun.
There are billions of rogue
planets roaming the Milky Way,
not bound to any host star.
One of them has been spotted on
the edge of our solar system.
What if this interstellar
object swung through it?
How would this space invader
affect the orbits of the planets?
Could it possibly push earth
out of the habitable zone?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if a
rogue planet entered our solar system.
If a planet doesn't belong to any star
system, it's considered a rogue planet.
This is an interstellar
planet with a catchy name,
just 20 light years away from us.
It's nearly 17,000 times the size of
earth and has a powerful magnetic field
that makes the planet glow
with incredible Aurora's what?
F This massive alien planet trespass
the borders of our solar system.
Would this mean the end
of life here on earth?
Once the interstellar planet
invaded our solar system,
things could go very wrong.
This rogue planet would likely be moving
at hundreds of kilometers per second.
If we were unlucky enough to be on a
collision course with this massive alien
object, the earth would be completely
demolished, but don't worry.
Our solar system is quite big and the
chances of the rogue planet bypassing us
without a fatal collision are pretty high.
Instead,
our interstellar guests would be busy
disturbing the orbits of all the planets
in the solar system.
That's because of rogue planet.
Nearly 13 times bigger than Jupiter
would have a huge gravitational impact
making other planets orbits,
including Earth's more elliptical,
and that's when the bad news
begins for life. Here on earth,
the earth is orbiting.
The Sun's relatively narrow,
habitable zone within the zone,
also known as the goldilocks zone.
It's not too cold, so our water
doesn't turn to ice and not too hot,
so it doesn't get vaporized,
and neither do we just perfect changed
the Earth's orbit and the conditions for
life won't be so great.
The road planet may not push
us out of the habitable zone,
but it would bring us much closer to
the sun for very short and exceptionally
hot summers.
Those extreme summers would be followed
by long and super cold winters.
Quick Summers would leave us less time
to grow crops by the end of our first
never ending winter. Humanity could
face food shortages, even extinction.
The earth might be thrown into the next
ice age. Instead of global warming,
we'd be worried about global cooling.
We'd rethink our energy sources and try
to pump out more greenhouse gases to
warm the planet up.
A little solar energy on the other hand
would be considered very inefficient in
the wintertime,
but could be used very effectively
during the short blaze of summer count on
things being much worse. If the earth
gets knocked out of the habitable zone.
At that point,
the earth would consider a bleak cooldown.
All our water would
freeze and so would we.
This would be the end
of most life on earth.
The only way we could survive would be
if we learn to live at the bottom of the
ocean next to deep sea thermal vents
that push out extremely hot water.
Maybe eventually we'd evolved
into a different life form
that would take control
over the frozen planet. Lucky
for us, the universe is enormous.
There's a lot of space between rogue
planets and other objects in our galaxy,
and that makes this
scenario very unlikely.
But what if something did cause us
to evolve into another species? Well,
that's a story for another.
What if.